Before we talk about cognitive architectures in more detail,
first let us characterize what is a cognitive agent.
Now, there are many views of what a cognitive agent is. Here is
one characterization of cognitive agent which is very popular in modern AI.
A cognitive agent is a function that maps a perceptual history into an action.
So it's B asterisk map into A where the asterisk on P stands for
the history percepts. So this characterization says that one of the major tasks
of cognitive agents is to select actions. You're driving a car. What action
should you take next? You're having lunch, what action should you do next?
You're conversing with someone, someone else, what action should you do next?
All the time we are taking actions, we as humans. And the question is,
what should we do next? We base that action in part on the history of
percepts in that particular situation. So this characterization
captures the basic notion of cognitive agent in a very concise manner.